emic talks about his new collection of
essays entitled reporting at an event
hosted by the Smithsonian associates in
Washington DC this is about an hour my
name is Barbara tousling I'm the
director of the Smithsonian associates
and I'm delighted to welcome you here
this evening for a very special program
tonight we're going to hear about public
people world leaders dissidents authors
athletes who will be brought to life
beyond the pages of the books of the
magazines that we read beyond our TV
screens and the movie screens in this
discussion led by Robert Siegel David
Remnick the New Yorkers gifted editor
and writer brings fresh insights and
rare access into very public lives our
interviewer tonight is Robert Siegel who
I'm sure all of us know and what's
interesting about radio personalities is
you know his voice but now you'll you'll
have a chance to meet him in person mr.
Siegel is the senior host of NPR's
evening news magazine all things
considered he began his career in
college radio and in 1968 he anchored
coverage of the protests and police
actions at Columbia University on the
Columbia radio station wkc R he says it
in the 38 years since he's learned to do
absolutely nothing else but with all due
respect we disagree since joining NPR in
1976 he's been a newscaster an editor
the network's first foreign staffer in
London the head of NPR news and since
1987 a host of all things considered in
that job he gets to do in his words some
reporting and a lot of interviewing and
that's certainly our good fortune this
evening as he will be interviewing our
other distinguished guests David Remnick
mr. Remnick has been the editor of The
New Yorker since 1998 and I expect
you're going to be preaching to the
choir here I think we all have
subscriptions and he's been a staff
member there since 1992 and prior to
this he spent 10 years on the staff of
the Washington Post
he's the author of the Pulitzer
prize-winning Lenin's tomb a collection
of New Yorker profiles in the last 15
years and he's also the author of
resurrection the devil problem and the
national bestseller king of the world
which Time magazine selected as
top nonfiction book of 1998 his most
recent book reporting writing from The
New Yorker is available for sale after
our program this evening mr. Remmick has
a flight to catch immediately after the
program to close the magazine tomorrow
and also to do a little work on today's
top story but he very kindly arrived
early so he could sign the books so
there are signed copies of his book
available for sale so without further
ado let me introduce these very two
special gentlemen and please join me in
giving them a very warm welcome to the
Smithsonian
[Applause]
hello David all right it's nice to talk
with you once again good to see you
let's talk about reporting which is the
the title of your book and there's both
an historical reference to reporting and
also a description of what you do your
reporter well does it sound that strange
reporting I
that's all I've done that's all I have
ever really wanted to do ever since I
became a newspaper junkie as a kid
reporting means showing up accumulating
learning finding out and in the case of
this kind of reporting of finding some
way of through character or narrative to
make a complex person realizable or a
narrative move along or a political
issue understandable it for example it
means going to a place like Gaza now
Gaza is to the immediate visitor chaos
how do you make order of that how do you
make narrative order of that political
sense of it how do you find somebody
that will be your Informer that's the
skill that's the set of skills that's
brought into play so far from Gaza
you're driving you're being driven along
the Housatonic and Philip Roth's Volvo
all right and you're interviewing you're
talking with him you're not quite
interviewing him it's a very it's a very
these are these are known people these
are people who haven't met their first
reporter when they met me they didn't
just fall off the publicity turnip truck
and they know that the only kind of
interview is not just what we're doing
now this kind of formal across a table
with the tape recorder with the notes it
also they know that the action in front
of us the interaction between us unless
otherwise specified is fair game so
Philip Roth doing schtick in the car as
we
as we ride by this frozen river he is
not unaware I would think that this is
going to possibly be part of this very
strange transaction he's the interstate
you are scribbling recording remembering
the thinking anything that works
anything that works anything that
doesn't disrupt but anything that is
going to is going to be accurate in
other words my memory is not the best I
have the kind of memory that if I were
to read Bleak House say I would get to
the last page and I would have loved it
of course wonderful novel and then I
could start at the very beginning and
not have any sense that there was a
legal case at issue or jaundice versus
who I'd never heard of it III need to
write things down and so I've been known
sometimes you'll be at a say at a dinner
with somebody and it doesn't seem quite
right to be taking notes or taping the
extra trip to the bathroom whatever
works now I don't I don't cheat I don't
you know when there's an agreement that
something's off the record these things
have very specific meanings
I don't violate those and as you know at
The New Yorker we have effect checking
Department and so all these people get a
phone call saying whether it's Philip
Roth or even Alexander Solzhenitsyn well
not really Alexander Solzhenitsyn was
mostly his wife and his instance did you
really tell Remnick X they don't read
the quote back to them but they the
essence of the quote is that you wish
you were six feet tall or ten feet tall
or whatever it is and they say yes or no
that's the fact check let's see yes an
example of the famous New York effect
yet it's very very thorough and if
you've ever been on the other end of it
it's it's I think it's reassuring and as
an editor it allows me to go to bed at
night and actually get some sleep so as
a as a reporter what is it that the
return of so units into Russia and Mike
Tyson biting off a part of Evander
Holyfield's ear what do they have in
common that that says to you I
I want to write it back absolutely
nothing of course I'm glad to hear today
I mean I I went to as you might imagine
there were subjects in the human
experience that Tina Brown was more
eager for me to cover than professional
price fighting a professional price
fighting at this point is like a cult
sport zero women are interested in it
were close to zero and about 0.5 percent
of the male population it's it's it's
it's really on its way out with the
exception of some communities Hispanic
communities Southern California and
Texas Nevada senators exactly right if
they can get the right price on the
ticket and and I remember going to see
Holly field versus Tyson you remember
this fight you all look like fight fans
it's just all the cigar smoke in the
room it's incredible it's that New
Yorker magazines st. Nick's arena yes
and so Tyson clearly discovers that he
can't be Holly filled easily and that's
what Holly field that's what Tyson is
all about the quick knockout he can't do
it so he finds he's looking for a way
out and so he's gonna cheat so he bites
Holly fields ear the first time which is
quite wonderful you know he kind of gets
his head into the neck and as if he's
looking for a truffle like a pig looking
for that and he fights and once in
Hollywood jumps up and down and the
press corps is outraged their moral
outrage and I'm delighted how are they
outraged this is a sport in which the
object of the sport is to induce a
hematoma on the other guy and render him
unconscious and possibly crippled for
life but ear biting
which is kind of old-fashioned
endearment and and even even a kind of a
sexual maneuver if you want to get
specific about it nothing that I was
ever very good at but I had a very
narrow range and I used the past-tense
advisedly I was delighted because I knew
that this was going to be something
extraordinary and the great thing is he
did it again and he was disqualified and
all the writers were you know they it's
as if they had discovered that their you
know their spouse was cheating on them
or their favorite senator had had had
hidden lots of cash in his refrigerator
freezer or something like that to me
that's a story but you know and but less
comically mike tyson is a tragic figure
you know he's a guy with lots of pieces
missing as a human being and he's a
combination for a writer of in
nonfiction of some figure out of richard
wright and just ascii he's a dark
screwed-up guy who's self-aware he and
he's able to articulate it and what I
like about boxing and if it disappeared
tomorrow I couldn't care less I have to
be honest but what I liked about boxing
and liked about boxing is a writer Derek
Jeter is impossible to write about he
does he needs you like he needs a third
eye he has so much money he has his PR
guy and you remember the scene in Bull
Durham where Kevin Costner teaches Tim
Robbins how to talk to the press and we
got a good ball club we have a real good
ball club I want to thank the Lord for
his my ability to hit a curveball and so
on try to write that you fill up your
notebook at in some locker room and you
come back and you realize it's just it's
just bilge it's just nonsense boxers
don't like that boxers will tell you
everything and anything because there's
somehow so grateful for your attention
and it's always been like this and
straight ahead of guy list in that sense
the most part yeah the then you also see
these guys as part of a kind of sort of
mythic pageant of heroes and villains
who pass through well first of all it
can it everybody raise your hand
you can name the heavyweight champion of
the world not one first of all there
eight there are 18 of them because don't
have enough hands great that's the
problem but nobody can name one right
they've a glee think as a Ukrainian guy
maybe they're not sure okay in the 1950s
in the sporting world there were three
sports that the main sports writers
wanted to cover
horse racing which is now a mere betting
vehicle and only very few people go
actually go to it except for on the big
races boxing which as I said is now a
cult sport and baseball which is still
popular so things completely changed and
now it's a little bit like going to I
don't know a session of New Orleans
voodoo or tarot card readings or
something like that yes you explained to
me that you got to cover boxing and the
sports Department of Hawaiian Post cover
box because it worthy it was the least
desirable sport when I got to cover I
after I was a horrendous failure as a
night police reporter they said well
maybe you'd like sports meaning you're
gonna take sports and the the assignment
was this you may not complain for two
years because complaining is a newsroom
art and I was quickly on my way to
becoming a master and so you may not
complain for two years you do this and
there was a sports editor George Solomon
who had a strange notion of geography
Jordan you would go and you would cover
some game in California and he'd say
while while you're out there the
University of Oklahoma is playing in
Norman but it was it was just a group of
single kids basically 22 23 year olds
making very little money and happy as
could be and running around and learning
how to report how to write fast you know
it wasn't exactly Watergate but you
learned something very I couldn't have
yeah and and my cohort was you know
Michael Wilbon and and and Tony
Kornheiser who were now very wealthy and
their ability to concentrate on one
thing brought vast rewards and a very
self-effacing about your newspaper
career to the point of you claimed that
when you were when you were Moscow
I don't want to be falsely modest I
learned everything I really if I'm good
at anything I learned because nobody
else wanted to I swear to you nobody
else really wanted to go to Moscow it's
very cold and and it's really it was
inexplicable because this revolution was
really obvious in beginning it was 1987
and I got to go and and it was
extraordinary and I learned how to be a
news reporter and I probably learned how
to write a little bit and I learned
everything about politics about the
world I got out of my own adolescent
self I got out of the newsroom it meant
the world to me I mean what that
revolution meant a lot more than just
David Remnick little career but for me
it was a godsend and even a bad reporter
would have done just fine because the
stories were you know like picking large
apples right in the middle of the
harvest season Russia had been something
that interested you before that the
books not the politics remember the
politics were boring unless you were a
Soviet ologist
covering the Soviet Union prior to
Gorbachev was like covering a secret
like covering and overhearing a
conversation through a thick wall and
Rick Smith and Bob Kaiser in that
generation of really talented Russian
reporters were doing an entirely
different thing and then when I got
there and Bill Keller and Michael Dobbs
and my wife Esther fine was with the New
York Times suddenly after 70 years of
not being able to say a word and and say
nothing of centuries of absolutism and
entire people an entire empire wanted to
do nothing more than talk to the few
reporters that were there it was an
endless conversation and you do claim
though that you managed to leave the
country at precisely the the wrong
moment yeah I'm not a reporter fantastic
and unerring instincts on in you know
your time comes up and for foreign
correspondents and the Washington Post
is usually unless you're in Iraq and you
you're gonna burn out if you don't get
out a lot
often three four maybe five years
because they've made a large investment
you have to learn Russian and language
lessons and all the rest but your time
comes up they don't want you to go
native I think the expression is as if
somehow you're going to become the
Kremlin House reporter and so and what
happens very often in these places is
you get a kind of farewell gift from
some sources they'll give you a big
interview or something and Gorbachev's
main liberal advisor was named Alexander
Yakovlev Dodd I think last year and he
very very very rarely spoke to the press
and I got this fantastic long interview
in early mid August of 1991 and he told
me all about his life and he I you know
I was writing a book I knew that by then
and I knew I wanted to have a chapter on
yakovlev and and he said in the by the
way David I believe there will be a coup
let perhaps by KGB and upcoming this
party I write it down I lead the story
with it because I'm I'm not that big a
full front page and then we have picnic
picnics and all this all this business
and we get on an airplane my wife and I
and on our baby then a better year old
and we fly to New York and we get picked
up and by my in-laws and we go to their
house and it's about eleven o'clock
twelve o'clock and I turn on CNN and
there are tanks going by our apartment
building because there was a coup led by
KGB Communist Party actually and and I
was big schmuck
and so I dictated over the phone a
what's called politely a news analysis
and it was actually I've been wrong
about a lot of things but the news
analysis said that it was unlikely that
this coup could hold for long because so
much had changed and so on and so forth
so I was mildly right about that and I
thought the next morning I will get the
next flight out and I'll be back in
Moscow by the afternoon I will have
missed a day suddenly the heavens open
and a literally a hurricane I don't know
if you remember this in August 19 some
of you are old enough to remember there
was a hurricane
unbelievable hurricane all of Martha's
Vineyard was washed into the sea and
this kind of thing and there was I
figured well no flights but I have to
try but when I get to Moscow there'll be
tanks and they'll turn me back anyway
but I have to try one flight leaves from
Kennedy Airport a Lufthansa flight makes
it to Frankfurt Frankfurt to Moscow get
there and no tanks I was at the
barricades I barely missed the thing so
I made big mistake but I how you say a
rectified you had the scoop on the
revolution with you then this as our
Secretary of Defense says ever so often
stuff happens
the first article in the in your
anthology in your collection here is
about Albert and indeed it's your you're
quite ahead of the curve besides comedy
mister mister stand after comma the
Shecky Greene of American politics I I
had I had occasion to quote variety last
week that it is doing his movie is doing
boffo biz in limited release book a book
about a movie about a slideshow is
debuting at number three on the New York
Times bestseller list which is only
slightly ahead of the sails of reporting
writings from The New Yorker number
three and a half thousand on your amazon
you within rocket the story that's in
the book there's one that was a shorter
item much more recently about in
Inconvenient Truth but the story here
was done a few years ago when Al Gore
had been had been defeated in two
thousand and now is doing the slide she
did yeah well I wanted to I appealed
look reporting is is not the kind of
sausage-making you want everybody to see
and my appeals to Kareena Gore were
probably in the department that there
were as a film of that lunch
maybe it's it wouldn't be the most
dignified thing but that you do that you
appeal to family members you do what you
have to do within the boundaries of
total humiliation and the course decided
finally they were gonna stop this and
this silence because he had you there
you as a remember the election ended
let's just put it that way and gore made
his speech withdrawing which might have
been his most emotionally elegant moment
of his political life surely was and
rather like Galileo saying it still
turns as he as he as he left the stage
and then he grew a beard and he gained
weight and he sailed around in the
Mediterranean and he did a few teach
gigs but he was you could tell that he
was not eager to rejoin the fight or the
political scene then he did and I went
to see him and he was starting what I
would call this kind of wilderness
campaign making very direct speeches
about Iraq about the environment about
civil liberties about all these issues
where Bush had certainly become far well
the whole business of the compassionate
conservative and semi I shall i
salaciousness trakone candidate had been
forgotten and he was in a mood to talk
and if you and I'll and a lot of
reporting as in life is showing up and
if you show up at the right time and
hold your bucket out you will get rain
if you ask the right questions or shut
up enough to let it happen and that's
what happened there and he also you know
he's that weird very human combination
of he's very funny at this he's very
smart but pedantic he's very funny
and yet the camera light goes on and
suddenly something happens to his whole
body you know he's a he's a more of a
natural teacher than maybe he has a
politician although he got more votes
for the presidency than anyone alive in
the history of the United States I
should we should remember and to that
time until until the the Kerry Bush
election and so you know now he is I
think he seems some happy in this I
don't want to be a shrink as it's not
interesting to me but the next question
obviously is is he gonna run for
president 2008 or at least it is to me
and I think it it is you know less than
50% chance of that because you'd have to
the psychodrama of running against
Hillary whom he does not care for and
it's the act of running for president
which is so onerous and hard and for him
especially for him not the fun part he's
knock Bill Clinton's the opposite of
Bill Clinton thrives on that political
battle he loves going into big crowded
rooms he leaves the room with more
energy than he
had coming in Gor leaves the room
exhausted like a normal person he's not
a natural and so and he's mate and by
the way he's making some money you know
Google Apple he's clearly become a quite
wealthy man we don't know the specifics
of it but it's pretty clear and he's got
this issue which after all only involves
the fate of humanity on earth it's not
tax reform or reinventing government
even I think he's reinvented himself as
what I'm saying very successfully and it
made a natural peace to start the book
with yeah I you know I the book starts
with a series of political pieces that
are very in the moment there's one about
Tony Blair and there's one about Katrina
a kind of piece of the closest thing in
that book to what by New Yorker
standards anyway would be called
deadline reporting and then there were a
lot of literary interviews I'm including
both of your associates and pieces here
as literary there's a piece about
translations from Russian there's Philip
Roth as I didn't read I did the piece
about the Russian translators because I
wanted to sell out and sell a lot of
books I thought that was no I look I'm
I'm interested in a in a couple of areas
of the world intensely I'm as an editor
I'm interested in everything that comes
my way from writers I get to be it's a
very lucky job in a million ways one of
them is my curiosity about the world
gets to be indulged by saying to Ryder X
what about such-and-such why don't you
write about that and they by the way
they say no all the time I then but you
you get to indulge this curiosity as an
editor but as an editor and as a writer
and as a human being I like to get out
of the house once in a while I don't
think I'd be even a decent editor if I
just only stayed in that office building
on Times Square and I'm interested
very very particularly obviously in in
Russia or the former Soviet Union or the
former Imperium which takes up a lot of
land by the way and something that takes
up a lot less land but is far more
disputed and that is the
israeli-palestinian
war debate issue occupation and so so
there there are several pieces on each
of those things I'm also interested
where where where writers are concerned
about the business of exile and the
business of the writer as a public actor
and so there are pieces about
Solzhenitsyn both when he was living in
Vermont and what I where I got to know
him and when he moved back to Moscow
where he lives now and but Slava vaclav
havel as well so the I'm intensely
interested in those things do you think
that you're a better reporter for being
an editor so much of the time now no no
absolutely not
there's less time and if I thought even
writing these pieces somehow cut in in
any serious way
to my work as an editor I would quit all
of it I have to and I owe that much to
the magazine and my colleagues and the
project of the New Yorker I would not
look I would not have become an editor
and I had been an editor of absolutely
nothing before the editor of The New
Yorker and at a newspaper what happens
is you're a reporter and then maybe you
become the assistant city editor and
maybe the city and then you kind of go
up through these things and then there's
that competition at the end the big
bake-off for executive editor and that's
the way it works it's a big institution
The New Yorker is something different
and my previous editing experience
before becoming the editor of The New
Yorker was I was the editor of the
Pascack Valley smoke signal in Hillsdale
New Jersey which was a distinguished
high school newspaper that came out
twice a year and I wrote all the
articles and did all the headlines and
cut them out from I still do that from
the act of getting other writers stories
into shape and figuring out when they're
not doing enough of that or doing too
much of that doesn't it doesn't come
back to you and your own reporting what
doesn't I think editing and writing meet
at certain points but almost like a
figure 8 they meet at a point but and
and riding are entirely different things
they're involved perhaps and in the case
of the New Yorker in the same project
but my life as a writer for The New
Yorker was a fairly solitary one which
suited me just fine
I had my thing I went on my trip got the
fixer did the work at the translator if
need be and worked on it in in and I
went into an office because I have kids
and it's noisy but I locked myself in an
office worked maybe come out for a
little schmooze athan with my colleagues
which is a kind of a relief but I was by
myself just by myself all day and then
and then social life began at night or
wherever and an editor it's it's it's
not the same
so she anything a magazine is a largely
social transaction what's your job your
job is to think about the project of the
magazine overall about that week but
also to encourage writers to support
them to talk with them about their
pieces to maybe sometimes prod them if
necessary because something's gone off
the rails to encourage to get somebody
else in a sense to do their best work to
do their best individual work this is a
magazine where the readers know who the
writers are only very sophisticated
newspaper readers or political junkies
know you know many by lines other than
the columnist sense and sports writers
in in a newspaper they just don't
especially on the front page
cognoscenti do but New Yorker readers
all of them they're looking for Anthony
Lane on the movies or George Packer and
John Lee Anderson anorak or Joe NACA
challenge and stay there the the left
side of the table of contents is every
bit as important as the right side
nobody necessarily cares what Anthony
Lane is going to focus his comic
monologue on this week we're the you
know The Da Vinci Code is a kind of an
inert movie but not in Anthony lanes
hands it becomes it becomes a comic
Diffie ram whatever that word means
thinking of star wars part 3 right his
hands rise one of the funniest movies of
the funniest review the movie was less
than her lessons Larry it was one Star
Wars movie that I saw but so far as I
could tell I get the older I got the
less I could understand Star Wars movies
and one of them seemed to be about
intergalactic insurance policies there
was something having to do with
insurance but I digress to digress
one of the questions that has figured
very very prominently in your editorship
for several years now is Iraq the war in
Iraq constant subject how do you how do
you regard the magazine's treatment of
the war on Iraq well I think our
coverage has been rather remarkable the
two people that have covered it on the
ground are John Lee Anderson who was
there from the very start and who had a
lot of experience in Iraq beforehand and
who's an expert war reporter one of the
very few print reporters who stayed
throughout the bombardment of Baghdad
like an Garrels of NPR like people a
couple at the Washington Post New York
Times but it was a very small corps at
that time I'm not talking we didn't have
in embed it's not that there was
anything wrong with that but we we don't
we're not equipped with a big Bureau say
we have to pick our spots and how to do
things individually and then George
Packer got hired
pretty soon into this and who had had a
lot of experience certainly in in the
run-up to the war on the intellectual
foundations such as they are and were
about the war so and then he got
involved in on-the-ground reporting and
as it happens it's my belief that not
only is their reporting vid
extraordinary for The New Yorker but
they've written the two best books about
the war the assassins gate assassins
gate by George Packer and and and the
the bombing of Baghdad they did Baghdad
book by John Lee Anderson and they
continued to go in and out and it's but
I have to say as a an editor I thought I
thought having been in some dangerous
places
that I would never ask a reporter to do
something that I wouldn't do and I'm
afraid that the nature of the war is
such and the nature of the coverage of
the war such that I've had to violate
that now I certainly don't insist on
anybody going and and in fact John Lee
when he was inside Baghdad as the it
became clear the bombing was going to
begin I urged him to really think about
getting out and but he's an adult and
he's very experienced and in this
situation more experienced than I am by
a lot and he made the decision himself
but you know you are immensely aware as
the editor of a magazine or a newspaper
that has correspondents in harm's way
that you could be making that phone call
to that to the wife or to the mother and
and it's it's no fun not an easy thing
well I got a phone call one day I mean
think enough time is elapsed where I
think I can tell this story I got a
phone call at one point in the early
part of the insurgency that somehow John
Lee had started interviewing people in
the insurgency which was a very
dangerous thing to do even at that early
stage and the insurgents didn't believe
he was a reporter and clearly the CIA
had means of monitoring their
conversations in the insurgency and I
got a call at some ridiculous lunch some
some affair I don't know what it was and
it was this official at the CIA saying
you better get this guy out because he's
going to be in trouble and unfortunately
John Lee at that point was not in
Baghdad which was the easiest path out
of Iraq he was in I believe somewhere in
the south and he had to make a long car
ride to get to Baghdad and then out and
I just it was and then to have to tell
him and to tell him that he was in this
kind of danger that's that's that's
pretty hard What did he say he had no
choice even John Lee knew when he when I
told him what that he should get out for
a while he should let it cool off and he
did he did he was there writing a piece
about about the beginning of this this
insurgency a Sunni insurgency
I'm asking about the New Yorker you know
there is so many daily news
organizations right now are in this
state of constant panic over either
declining readership if their newspaper
or the failure to connect with young
audiences or the advent of the Internet
and a they take it for free culture the
development did you live in fear at the
New Yorker of the magazine's future of
the future of the genre of the magazine
be a fool not to think about the future
of the whole enterprise
I come from the Washington Post I
learned everything that I could possibly
that I possibly know about journalism
from being there for ten years and
covering all these things and also
inhaling the air the ethical air the the
sense of an enterprise in an institution
at the Washington Post and I talked to
my colleagues once in a while and
circulation has gone down in a
precipitous way no matter how great that
newspaper is and yet and there at the
same time their internet site which is
fantastic and the New York Times is as
well has grown enormous ly lots and lots
of new readers but they it's it's the
trick is figuring out how to make those
new readers become part of a business
how is that business going to succeed on
the same level or even better as the
Washington Post pre-internet because if
it doesn't how are you going to spend
the kind of money that you need to spend
to do reporting reporting is expensive
you can be sure that every great piece
that one or series of pieces that one
fuel it surprises this year and there
was some remarkable ones stretching from
NSA wiretapping to Dana priests
extraordinary stuff on on secret prisons
or our own stuff it costs it costs in
terms of the time you need to give a
reporter in terms in terms of
infrastructure all this so you bet I
think about it now that said this
existential crisis has not hit magazines
at least my magazine the way it has
newspapers and there are reasons for
that the best technology still for
reading The New Yorker is this thing
so far because we run longer pieces now
another generation might not think that
and I think we have to be there to
figure out a way to either have it on
paper and online or eventually all I
don't know how that's going to go who
knows but you better be there in advance
with something that that that's going to
support you and so that this enterprise
of humor and fiction and reporting and
all the rest can continue and thrive it
is foolish to sit there and go well I
think the New Yorker is best on paper
and that then we're not gonna do
anything about that well that's just
dumb that's just just foolish and that's
you know ignoring the obvious you talk
about attracting younger readers of
putting things in the magazines no I
just I well having one spinny on the
reader
we're both younger than some other
readers we should say or there's not
it's not over all together
barely barely oh I'll tell you what the
principle that as I see it of The New
Yorker is the following I care that you
like this magazine and you want it to be
good but that's it
I appreciate beyond measure the loyalty
of readers to the New Yorker and it is
immense and deep I can't get over it and
part of the fun of coming into talking
with people as you you feel that and you
also get criticism and that's and that's
part of engagement too but I am here to
tell you that the New Yorker I am NOT
trying to guess what you want to read on
a given week or you or you or you
I'm not trying to guess whether you
think this short story is going to be
great or moving or this cartoon funny
all I can do is depend on my own wits
and this very small circle of people
around me kind of a cosa nostra thing
it's this thing of ours and we then hope
you like it
no test-marketing no focus groups it's
this homemade thing your test is would
you like it with
with the group of you like yes now
sooner or later if everybody stopped
reading it it would be it might be under
suspicion that my taste is not exactly
appealing but so far so good now people
are gonna hate stuff or they're gonna be
bored by stuff or they're gonna think
I'm obsessed with a subject or or our
writers or obsession okay I can accept
that but I'm not gonna change it unless
I think it's wrong unless I think we're
going in a wrong but that's what an
editor is supposed to do not test the
waters not dip the finger in at least
where the New Yorker is concerned that's
how we do it I don't say that out of I
tell you it is the opposite of
condescension or opt the opposite of
patronizing I I think have you do you
ever or get started on a story as a
reporter and find that it's a total dog
and that this this profile will never
see the light of day is most of the time
most of the time
most of the time I mean it's like the
seven stages of grief know you I find on
foreign trips you have the following
experience you you show up and in the
first day since you don't know anything
in about 36 hours you are over you just
I'm going to need 50,000 words here and
it's gonna be fantastic and then the
things you thought you knew after week
you then the reverse is true after two
weeks and then you're confused and the
person you wanted to focus on is the
wrong person and you're ready to get on
the plane and go home or the it's all
gonna go to hell and then you come home
and maybe you're more enthusiastic and
you had my favorite part dirty secret
it's not the reporting it's the flying
home with full notebooks part most
people don't like to write most
reporters love the reporting part and I
I like the reporting part okay but you
have to remember that reporting is a lot
of as you know as well as anybody a lot
of reporting is waiting around taking
the flight to Cleveland that's delayed
for four hours and then the guy doesn't
show up and you know there's a it's a
kind of a humbling experience I mean for
Bob Woodward it might be going in the
front door the White House but
for the rest of us Nagi's it's something
a little bit different al gore accepted
and I love this feeling of I've got
something here I have fish now it's time
to make soup and because I really
believe in the kind of infinite
possibilities or almost infinite
possibilities of non-fiction writing and
within the realms of fact of being able
to tell a story and finding out
structures for that and the sentences
for that and how to go about that to me
that's magical work even if I fall short
every single time to me that's it's it's
physically I like doing it the
possibilities of nonfiction writing
I wondered in reading you on on Roth and
DeLillo and Havel and associates and the
Russian translators whether there was or
whether you are or have ever been a
closet no closet novelist yeah and you
want me to come out of the closet here
on this particular stage I know I'm
still in a closet
on that are there a lot of notebooks in
the closet or is it no I think every
nonfiction writer sooner or later is a
liar unless he or she fesses up and I
also do think as much as I believe in
the infinite possibilities of nonfiction
know that there are limits to it if you
are true to the word nonfiction and
facticity and all the rest and I don't
believe in cheating and we can discuss
that that there are things that fiction
can do that nonfiction can't necessarily
do certainly in the SubGenius category
which I certainly count myself as a
full-fledged
member so you don't believe you don't
believe in cheating you mean there is a
certain amount of illusion implicit in
assembling from many many different
places tiny little story even construct
a fact you have arranged those facts for
a comic effect or a news analysis effect
or tonal effect or whatever it is or
just because it's going through the
instrument of you and your sensibility
in your mind and your deficiencies and
your plusses and minuses
yes so when do you think it turns into
cheating I think when you help the facts
alone when you guess at the state of
mind of people when you know you don't
have something nailed down but you think
it's probably true when it's too good to
check and a thousand little sins begin
adding up and up and up and then you are
halfway to hell and I'll say this there
are authors that I think aren't
wonderful and I suspect or no and living
or dead that they practice a form of
what we might call non fictional magical
realism which is and I think times have
changed on these questions too not in my
house I want to read those authors and
if they are self presenting themselves
in books I want to read them and I'll
figure it out for myself but I've got a
magazine to run in the sense that if I'm
going to publish sy Hersh or George
Packer
and jane mayer and tell you it's true
and even ask you to make the leap of
faith that these unnamed sources are
real things and not some made-up ghost
called a senior Pentagon official or
whatever the hell this label that we've
come up with I'm asking a lot of you a
hell of a lot and so if I'm going to put
a piece right next to it and also call
it nonfiction and it's a form of magical
realism then what am i doing to the
sahaj piece or the jane by implication I
won't do that I will not do it not not
in The New Yorker not while I'm around
and I and I think that's I think that's
understood by our readers now memoirs is
a very different category people
legitimately write memoirs and they
remember things when they're 12 years
old and you and I and we all know that
when you get together on Thanksgiving
and somebody says remember that time 20
years ago everybody has a completely
different version of this I think we
understand that on the other hand if you
deliberately go and you fake your arrest
I don't know where I'm getting this
detail from or some other you know a
fairy tale then I think that's cheating
even in the memoir category well I'm
gonna let I'm gonna let our our audience
put some questions to you after I just
tell one last story which seems to
remain to this which is that on the very
day that I interviewed you for for all
things considered I also interviewed
Philip Roth later and the same day and
and so actually I'd read Ross novel some
weeks earlier and haven't any man
excuse me every man yes and just before
that a couple of days I read your your
piece about Philip Roth re-read yours
there but Philip Roth in which Roth
declares I don't think about I don't
believe in death I don't think about
mortality it does whatever not much and
then I read this book and that is all
about thinking about death and mortality
and I read him tell me another one the
quote did the quote that he gave you
about that and his answer was so I tell
David one thing and I tell you something
so what we're getting sometimes is a
snapshot that's true true for that
particular even even in Philip at that
point when I did that that profile from
and he he talked about how sales had
diminished of serious fiction and then
the next book he wrote the plot against
America became a big bestseller so to
quote our Secretary of Defense stuff
happens
stuff happen but David Remnick thank you
very much and let's let's
[Applause]
between now and your - to the airport
let's take some questions from the
audience sir give us one phrase about
each one of them it you pulled away from
it than maybe we haven't read about or
something New Yorker is not known for
stories that are one phrase long I think
that's kind of in a tall order I really
don't know that I could do that but I
have to say if you're asking me maybe
what's the most impressive person or the
most enigmatic to turn your question
around a little deliberately it's
probably Alexander Solzhenitsyn
especially when I saw him in Vermont
here was somebody who one man against a
structure of power that's already
receding in our memories about how
powerful it was and to help forbidding
did what he did and wrote Gulag
Archipelago and changed
uncountable minds about the nature of
that regime not least in Western Europe
it was a very strange feeling and it has
a kind of nineteenth-century
countenance and and bearing and and
willfully prophetic both look and
admission in the world to go see him you
know in in in Vermont and meet his
children who were Red Sox fans and kind
of normalized Americans to a great
degree and sit at the lunch table with
him that kind of moment in reporting
doesn't come along very often and and
for me to try to make up as it were a
story of that was a great challenge
another there's a question in the rear
and could you speak up
popular poetry seems to be making a
comeback with several successful
anthology last year so it must all be
due to the your excellent choice of two
poems for weaken a New Yorker or 100 per
year do you ever think of adding a third
or sometimes poetry is an important
element of the of the magazine look I
don't necessarily think that everybody
reads everything in the magazine except
for one element of it and you know what
it is the cartoons 99% of the people say
they read the cartoons first and the
other 1% are lying you know I think just
the act of our being in the poetry game
of being a commercial magazine with a
circulation of over a million publishing
poetry the best we can and there are a
lot of poets out there and some very
very fine ones in in a society where the
greatest poet reading public might be
poets themselves I think it's a great
thing and so that people who wouldn't
normally buy a volume of poetry or a
chapbook or and who are not in their
phase and they're not in the Poetry game
to come across something by Louise Glick
or CK Williams or a young poet like Dana
Goodyear and maybe not be the most
trained poetry reader in the world and
be moved by it and have something click
in is a great thing it's something
different than the Quarterly's with with
very particularly literary audiences or
poetry or oriented audience so it is
important to me and I work very hard
with our poetry editor Alice Quinn to
make those very difficult choices
question here in the front row
[Music]
what's the question but what about the
differences comparisons difference
between the father's is the New Yorker I
were as different as human beings could
be and you know that the most important
figures obviously in the history of the
New Yorker and we're editors are
concerned the first two with all the
respect in the world to to Bob Gottlieb
and Tina Brown to whom I owe a lot but
Harold Ross invented this thing he
wasn't just the editor of the magazine
he thought it up with a bunch of his
cronies and they for fun for an
enterprise in that kind of spirit of
let's put on a show in 1920s Manhattan
and he one of the smartest things he did
was also hire a different personality
much quieter much more withdrawn deeply
cerebral figure named William Shawn to
be his managing editor his
second-in-command eventually and Shawn
even while being the number two was
instrumental in deepening the magazine
and adding the texture of long reporting
pieces particularly during the Second
World War and Ross was still the editor
when Hiroshima was published by John
Hersey but that was very much the idea
of William Shawn to devote the whole
issue to it so you know the magazine was
did not come out full blown as we know
it today or as you might have known at
1975 or whenever it was very difficult I
knee everything everything is less than
talk of the town length it's very much
of the comings and goings of Manhattan's
swells and the high life and the Jazz
Age and it's very witty in ways that we
can't quite understand now the way old
jokes do the cartoons weren't quite
cartoons yet the fiction wasn't there
yet the first profile in the first issue
of the magazine was one page long it was
a profile of the head of the
Metropolitan Opera in New York so there
were the germs the seeds of The New
Yorker but it took time to develop the
notion of having serious fiction didn't
come till really Katherine white Roger
angels mother
insisted on it and developed it and
because we couldn't afford Hemingway and
Fitzgerald who were expensive the the
ethos of finding young talent happened
and so Catherine White discovered this
young short story writer you know in a
railroad flat in Chelsea named John
Cheever so that element of The New
Yorker took on life so that's that's
what I'd say well then but to carry
forward the question you're a tradition
those are the things that typify earlier
developments of The New Yorker what do
you think describes the the Remnick
period I don't I wouldn't I'd let
somebody else do that and I'm far from
done and I it is quite obvious that
since September 11th and all the things
that we think of as September 11th it
was not just that attack but the two
wars and Islamic fundamentalism and all
those things that we've had to cover
think about deepen our understanding of
certainly has characterized certainly
the last five six years which is the
bulk of my time as editor I can't deny
that let's take a couple of more
questions sir your essays
however called the odd NACA paragraph
nod NACA however
yes you're right you should put a bridge
down the front under they new pologize
four lanes everywhere in the culture
everywhere
brevity snappiness get it over fast is
at a premium and you can get that
anywhere you want there's got to be
somewhere to go in the media in
magazines where you can breathe a little
bit where you can explain where you can
be funny and digress and now not all
some long pieces fail and they may fail
because they are not that they're too
long in and of themselves but because
they're dull or the narrative didn't
succeed on carrying you along I mean is
worn piece too long perhaps but not
really I mean you you you you need you
need to have room to Rend around a
little bit otherwise everything is going
to start sounding the same and
everything's gonna be structured the
same tell us the important stuff in the
first paragraph get it over with get
moving
we're busy I gotta go it's not a
newspaper it's meant to be there are
timely elements of the New Yorker
comment maybe a piece maybe a sigh
Hirsch piece whatever it is but I want
you to pick up that magazine you know
what I've got a flight today or I've got
a train trip I've got two hours to
myself on a Saturday I've buried the
kids under the lawn or something
whatever it is
I've got to an hour to myself and I'm
going to look Cherie ate in this piece
that might be very serious or eccentric
or whatever we're literary or whatever
it might be and is there an infinite
number of places to go for such things I
think there's a very finite number of
places to go for that and the next
week's magazine arrives and the next
week's magazine writer
there are too much than too little we
have time for one more question ma'am
ma'am
I couldn't invent two topics the Malcom
Gladwell thinks up nothin Gladwell is
probably one of his great profiles was
of Ron Popeil the inventor of the Ronco
jar and Bala cutter I you could put me
in a locked room with every encyclopedia
known to man and I couldn't think of
that Malcolm Gladwell is an original
Malcolm Gladwell he doesn't want to
cover the war he doesn't want to you
know go cover the g8 summit he is
interested in a very Suey generous set
of ideas he has it what what's
fascinating about Malcolm is the
directions that his mind takes him and
the thing about the New Yorker is that
he's allowed to go do it I knew Malcolm
at the Washington Post and we were we
were friends and Malcolm Malcolm didn't
want to go cover the fall the Soviet
unit abhorred him more but Malcolm
wanted to cover was a dog on death row
he did a profile of a dog on death row
he covered oddities of the science world
he has an original mind well David if it
is true that you at the end of reading
the Bleak House would completely forget
what happened at the beginning then many
of us have huge stacks of New Yorkers at
home than we did that we could share
with you and you could read
as if they're a really cold memento
where the guy forgets everything but
it's it's a great pleasure always to to
read your magazine to talk with you
thank you very much
[Applause]
to read articles by David Brevik visit
The New Yorker calm